r qui pousse l'europe à se passer de
l'énergie russe la commission européenne
propose son plan de bataille elle
annonce une enveloppe 300 milliards
d'euros bonjour pierre bénazet on vous
retrouve depuis bruxelles l'idée c'est
de mettre le paquet sur les énergies
renouvelables
effectivement c'est le gros plan de la
commission européenne pour faire face
d'une part aux ambitions du lié au chant
à la lutte contre le changement
climatique
elle a proposé déjà il ya un an un
paquet de lutte pour
arriver à faire en sorte d'atteindre les
engagements la neutralité carbone de
l'union européenne diminuer la part de
des énergies carbonées dans la
consommation européen dans la conscience
dans la consommation privée pardon ainsi
que dans celle évidemment des
entreprises et dans la part du transport
il y a eu en plus évidemment l'attak de
la russie contre l'ukraine qui a redonné
un petit peu un coup de projecteur sur
ce dossier et donc la commission
européenne a remis le la question sur le
métier elle propose des outils
spécifiques pour arriver à sortir de la
dépendance énergétique vis-à-vis de
toutes les énergies fossiles et
évidemment spécifiquement des énergies
fossiles importés de russie lé
commissaire la présidente de la
commission européenne ours est la fonte
de la hyène affirmé tout à l'heure que
entre l'an dernier et cette année on
était passé de 40% des importations
provenant de russie à 24% donc il ya
déjà eu un véritable effort et cet
effort ce n'est pas seulement de trouver
d'autres sources d'approvisionnement
c'est aussi mettre un peu le projecteur
sur les renouvelables la sortie des du
charbon la sortie des énergies carbonées
il faut des obligations d'arriver à un
nom un certain nombre de panneaux
solaires la réduction du de la réduction
de l'air conditionné en est et où toute
une série de mesures réduire la vitesse
sur autoroute qui doivent permettre très
rapidement de faire baisser de 5% par
exemple la consommation de gaz dans
l'union européenne
on misait tout il y a quelques années
sur l'éolien en europe et maintenant
c'est essentiellement le solaire la
commission européenne demande aux états
d'identifier des mesures éventuellement
contraignante mais ça ce sont les états
qui le décideront pour imposer des
panneaux solaires sur toutes les belle
construction en tout cas déjà sur toutes
les nouvelles constructions de bâtiments
publics et puis à terme sur les
nouvelles constructions de bâtiments
privés par exemple merci beaucoup pour
ce point pi